une fois que tu es assis tu ne peux pas partir le voir
ok sondage Twitter si tu pouvais rester
un âge pour toujours, qu'en serait-il de
l'âge que nous avons en ce moment sérieusement
parfois j'aimerais que nous puissions sortir
ensemble de cette stupide ville
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
vous vouliez savoir si elle a déjà parlé
de s'enfuir,
regardez ceci, voici le dernier site qu'elle a
visité. Slenderman, il s'attaque à des
jeunes innocents whoa,
je pense que c'est ainsi qu'il fait revenir Katie.
Ceux qui entendent sonner les trois cloches
acceptent son invitation.  quand tu entends le
premier tu dois fermer les yeux en ouvrant
les yeux
seulement une fois que tu as entendu le troisième il
aurait dans sa tête comme un virus certains il
prend certains médicaments fous une fois que tu le vois
tu ne peux pas me laisser voir  lui
[Applaudissements]
toi